Susy ceux qui sont impliqués, c'est que je pensais que
vous quittiez ce qu'elle a balancé comme ça sur
ce régime s'ils devaient être une
marque enfumée pour le jeu de Jen, je suis juste comme un
électeur professeurs d'énergie Kenichi critique
fissile zillion d'accord vraiment pour la leçon
arc tant pour il n'y a pas  APC a mis des
triples, elle s'assure enfin qu'elle est tout
facilement résultat en fait nous finirons sur
ces faisables Sisyphe même multi-parties un
homme hey
bonjour amusez-vous ici je suis James et
vous je suis James vous euh un Twitter ce qui se
passe ici suis  Je reçois le
traitement silencieux ou quelque chose que vous faites une
impression étrange de Robert DeNiro essayant
d'avoir une merde je veux dire êtes-vous malade
vous avez vraiment l'air d'essayer d'
avoir une merde vous les gars je ne fais pas ça
ne fais pas  le truc tu ne m'as pas
fait ça avant ne fais pas
ça serveur tu me dis le plat du
jour s'il te plait oh va te faire [ __ ] tous les trois
c'est juste une foire c'est juste un film ne
comprends pas  près de moi la dernière fois que tu as
essayé de me toucher je suis juste  t un acteur
jouant un personnage
je ne suis pas nous avons vécu ça avant
mec s'il vous plaît ne refais pas ça
regarde tu écris tu le veux je vais te le
donner euh je suis le professeur Charles
Xavier
comment ça va toi toi  Je pense que tu te
masses les tempes, ce que je n'ai jamais fait
avec deux doigts d'ailleurs, mais tu
penses à un ghetto, son nom est
probablement Claire Morgan, toi, tu
penses que Hugh Jackman est beaucoup plus
amical que nous et secoue plus
attirante et toi tu te demandes
si je vais prendre le poulet ou
le plat du jour c'est-à-dire
champignons et patates marbrées hein j'en
ai assez [ __ ] ah t'aurais du le
convaincre quand
même ben toi  voir une si belle adresse de bureau
légende buzzer voir pour avoir dit de plop la
Joconde particulière j'ai dit de vous laisser un
peu de parmigiano